oh hey captain did you get my report on
the finley murder
oh yeah i looked it over nice work good
thanks dad
why is everyone staring at me you just
called captain holt dad
he said thanks dad what no i didn't i
said thanks man do you see me as a
father figure peralta
no if anything i see you as a bother
figure cause you're always bothering me
hey show your father some respect i
didn't call him dad
no no no no jacob i take it as a
compliment it's not a big deal
i called vivian mom once and she's my
fiancee guys
jump on that boyle has psychosexual
issues old news
but you calling holt daddy hey daddy is
not on the table here
but you did call him dad dude you shut
up you've done nothing but lie since you
got here
all right all right i was lying about
the hold up but the dad thing that
happened
he admitted that his alibi was a lie it
was a trap all part of my
crazy devious plan i believed you
thank you son you want to talk about it
later over a
game of catch i'd like that topics to
avoid how my dad left us and ruined our
lives how my dad got remarried twice in
room to our lives how my dad moved to
canada and realized
i'm just gonna steer clear of your dad
entirely smart seriously why are you
dragging sales pizza through the mud
that place is special
why is it special because it's the best
pizza in the neighborhood well
according to charles's email blast it's
actually number eight captain reads my
blast
of course is the only one that measures
mouthfeel what are you kidding right now
this isn't about pizza
what's it actually about
when i was a kid i was shortstop on my
little league team oh my gosh
the truth it's not a brag my dad was the
coach and after every game he would take
the team to salz
halfway through our last season he left
me and my mom
and the worst part about it was that i
couldn't go with the missals anymore
well that's certainly not what i
expected this to be about
i'm sorry i'm sorry that happened to you
oh must be your birthday surprise you
got me the 86 mets
be warned a lot of them turned out to be
drug addicts so this could be a bummer
you ready
hey buddy happy birthday
dad what are you doing here i wanted to
surprise you
yeah well i am surprised that you know
it's my birthday
actually jake your father and i
are uh seeing each other again
oh wow that's that's so interesting
[Music]
oh
this is fine it's just the same that
it's always been i have to protect her
i'm gonna go down there and i'm going to
express my concerns to her in a calm
rational manner what are you doing mom
he's
evil all right sir i'm sorry that i got
in the middle of your family business
but i'm afraid i have to get in the
middle of it again
look i don't talk about this a lot but i
actually have had
a difficult relationship with one of my
parents yes your father you talk about
it obsessively wow
i would say obsessively i mean sure
there are times where i wish she was
there for me more but peralta
right sorry you dad you almost ready the
santiagos are very punctual
already out of the shower chill bro
don't call me bro i'm your son
okay dude dude is not an improvement oh
boy they're here
i was just about to call you guys ah
well no need to call because we are here
and we've got our deposit thank you so
much we just booked all our vendors
it's really happening yeah about that
wait what's wrong
something's wrong that's the look my mom
gave me right before she told me that my
dad left oh god did my dad leave my mom
again how do you know my mom and dad
now jake look i know every mistake your
father has made
and he says they are all in the past now
just
blow out your candles okay
great great idea mom i'll blow out my
birthday candles
i wish that you would leave damn it i
shouldn't have said it out loud that
won't come true
thank you for hitting my tat well thank
you for tatting my tit
and you know in a weird way i'm gonna
miss our little house yes and in an even
weirder way i think i might actually
miss you
huh and in an even weirder way i want
you guys to be my dads that
is weirder yeah i got stuff wait so you
risked
everything to get me and rose out of
prison
oh my god you did all of this for us
i love you dapton dapton it's cool new
way of saying captain
it's from the world of hip-hop love you
i think we have to help kyle
good i'm proud of you oh
yeah i'm sorry i just said you're proud
of me that's my tear trigger
all right let's go save kyle before the
dam breaks oh babe
our parents are vibing hard i know
drinking just makes people get along
better
do you think if i got my parents drunk
every day when i was a kid they would
stay together and we would have a happy
family probably
right yeah he's not lying about her
resume did you know the rock's character
in fast and the furious was based on her
hobbs or shaw she's not a hobbes or a
shaw if anything she's a trevor
that's the guy my mom dated after she
divorced my dad it's all about your
daddy issues stepdaddy issues this is a
new thing there was no one to look after
us
because our moms both worked and we
didn't have fathers
because divorce peralta i will not give
you a cool half mill because you had a
slightly sad childhood
go solve your housing crisis i want your
partner off the case what's his name
it's raymond holt oh
it's dad i mean captain holt i mean
captain dad i mean officer holt i mean
officer dad
yep that was it officer dad i found it
oh this is a nightmare
this is worse than my sixth birthday
party when i caught my dad making out
with a female clown in the bounce house
oh my dad is the worst going on why do
you want to mean private i need your
help with a case
three antique coins were stolen from my
classics department at columbia so why
not ask captain hold for help on the
case
wait are you guys getting a divorce i
can handle it this doesn't bring up any
weird issues for me
you encouraged me you kept saying mm-hmm
i was going through something difficult
you have no excuse he's kind of right
jake what was going on there i don't
know
i guess i'm just overly paranoid from
everything that's happened here you know
with kelly and wuntch and trevor and
rolf
who's ralph well my mom dated ralph
after she broke up with trevor he was
also a limo driver and he also cheated
on her the problem
is with limo drivers babe it's not it's
not no okay thanks i love you
ah jake i am excited that you're having
a kid thank you dad oh and hey if you're
free next friday we're having a sex
reveal party
why went to one of those in amsterdam i
would not invite
relatives but no no no it's a party
where we find out the biological sex of
the baby in a surprising way you better
hope you're having a girl
peralta fathers do not get along with
sons what that's not true i mean look at
us
we're doing better than ever this year
you even remembered my birthday month
things are good now but honestly it's
probably just a flip
it's fun to hear well it's just the way
it is it's the family curse i haven't
talked to my father
since you were 10. his dad abandoned him
at the world's fair his dad fled to
america
after drowning his dad in a well oh my
god
okay so yes fine there's a bit of a
trend but we are not cursed you and i
are good i bet you could even fix things
up with your dad
the admiral i always hoped that i could
reconcile things with him one day but
he's not gonna let that happen what can
i tell you
we're not meant to have sons there's a
demon in our jeans
totally your sex tape no the title of my
sex tape is cockpit larry and the mile
high steward eye
what stuart it's plural for stewardess
yeah okay
why'd you stop yelling look
oh thank god my wife and my dad are here
i mean
captain dad i mean i know who my dad is
it's you hi amy
hey what's holt's expression right now
would you describe it as proud daddy
it's hard to tell he's still piecing it
together this could take a while why
didn't you just
tell me what was actually happening i
wanted to sir but it involved trusting
madeleine lunch and i just didn't think
you could handle it
look i'm sorry that i lied to you
sir sir oh no is he mad i can't see
anything did he storm out
no i stormed in to tell you it was a
great play and nice work peralta
and there it is the proud daddy
you